[Music]
today's question comes from diane in
arizona my husband and i are in baby
step two and are working hard to pay off
our debt the one issue we struggle with
is not using credit cards we use them to
pay our utilities groceries and other
monthly bills but we never carry a
balance
by doing this we're able to travel for
vacations for free using our points
what's wrong with doing this if we're
not going into more debt
the age-old question dave
the age-old question we've been
exploring this topic on the fine print
because it's one of the biggest
objections
we get uh here at ramsey are people
going well dave i pay off my card every
month i get some free stuff what's the
harm
right so we should clue in
bank of america and chase
what portion of their marketing is
working the best
and it is this crap
the vacations the points this is the one
this is the one that's got people
believing in stupidity still
after all this time yep and here's what
happens and you can listen to the the
true cost of credit card rewards this is
the second fine print episode that we
released and we dug into this with an ex
capital one insider okay what did they
say uh she said they run 10 000
experiments a year on people to figure
out what's going to get them to spend
more to use the points and one of the
biggest ways they do it is through the
points because you know how the points
work they don't say it's 500 they say
you're going to get 128 000 points that
you can use to redeem flights that cost
74 000 and the points change every day
and there's blackout dates and there's
restrictions
and on top of that
uh the whole two percent cash back that
one is one of my favorites because you
know what two percent of a thousand
dollars is
twenty dollar
twenty bucks to spend a thousand and uh
that's not a great deal so let me let me
get this straight if you spend ten
thousand dollars
you get 200 bucks
ding ding ding that'll make you rich
yeah spend ten thousand get two hundred
that's a formula for wealth building
right there
we did an analogy did you people go to
grade school
listen diane here's the thing we did
this analogy in the in the podcast about
chuck e cheese because this is what it
reminded me of dave you go to chuck e
cheese oh my god gives you a ten dollar
bill and you get these coins claw on toy
story yes so you get your coins and
you're so excited to spend those coins
that you spent ten dollars on and you go
and you get all the tickets and you get
400 tickets and you go to the table at
the end of the day and you go wow i can
get any prize and they go nope you get
sticky hands and a pack of gum
and you go wow i spent ten dollars for
sticky hands and a pack of gum that cost
a quarter
yeah and i got screwed yeah i think so
uh here's the thing i don't have big
buildings dave uh the credit card
companies do they're sponsoring every
stadium in america and they're doing it
with billions of dollars that they're
making off of the backs of these people
who are overspending you
yes yeah so here's the thing
um
to start with
you're not going on vacation for free
that is an absolute asinine stupid
statement it is not true
you might have got your airline ticket
for free but everything else on the
vacation was not free so you're spending
money and you're going on vacation when
you should have been working because
you're in debt
you're not supposed to be going on
vacation when you're in debt
we follow everything you say no you
don't you don't go on vacation when
you're in debt and you don't go out to
eat when you're in debt you you work and
you work and you work and you clean your
dadgum debt up
and that is that that's the ramsey plan
now you can say you can you could go do
your plan if you want but don't say
you're doing my plan when you're going
on vacation because it's just not true
and here's the thing
the arrogance
that is required the intellectual
arrogance that is required for you to
think that you are taking on
billion-dollar companies who have
algorithms that know what bottled water
you drink
and you are somehow beating them and
you're you're you're fleecing them
you're getting an airline ticket and it
doesn't cost you anything you really are
pretty arrogant
to think that you're actually winning at
this game
i mean honestly
do you understand that when when
citibank when you call them your zip
code is pulled off your nsx code and the
person answering the call if it's a
friendly call
is a person of the same accent as you
if you call from the south you'll get a
syrupy southern bell accent and if you
call from the wicked northeast you'll
get a wicked northeastern accent
you're gonna these people screw with you
on levels you have no idea and you think
you're beating them
yeah absolutely incredible so here's the
thing we did study we did a study of
millionaires we studied 10 000 of them
10 167.
not a single one told us
we became millionaires with our free
vacation points because we ran all our
utilities our groceries and everything
else through a credit card and then we
went on vacation for free and it didn't
cost us anything and that's how we built
our wealth not one said that isn't that
odd
diane so here's the thing people that
ask this question are people that think
they're beating the system
let me tell you how you beat the system
you don't play
don't play in the system you know what
it's like it's like being a mouse in the
maze and you get to the cheese and you
think i won i got the cheese and you
zoom out and you go no i'm just a part
of a giant social experiment that exists
to take my money
that's what it is
so you can play that game and that's
fine you can get your vacations but i'm
not in the in the business of trying to
gain points i'm trying to gain wealth i
want to complete the baby steps i want
to pay off my house i want to give
outrageously and that doesn't happen by
paying off my card every month and
reaping the benefits of two percent cash
back you know the chucky cheese thing's
funny as crap oh it's great the team did
a great job with the edits we got the
coin sound
you got to go with them out of their ski
ball or whatever they're just coming out
there like crazy you've got this long
line of tickets and your little kid they
think they're getting the big prizes and
you get you never get the big price
nothing it's you got you spent 10 to 20
bucks to get a prize that cost less than
50 cents and the same thing's happening
when you go to book these flights and
you go well we can go to boise
yeah i don't think uh martinique was on
the list was it no
you're not going the bahamas first class
i don't think i'm sorry so belize and
bermuda are not on the list no no
so san diego's nonetheless nashville's
not on the list no it's blackout
blackout dates it's blackout mean they
don't go don't oh no they just won't
take you
that's what it means i i think you can
do a lot better by using a debit card
and using cash and saving up for your
own dang vacations yeah you know where i
go on vacation anywhere you want there
you go
that's how that works and you know when
i use those credit cards that always
works so that's how it happens i haven't
had a credit card and my gosh it's
george
it's coming up on 30 years
wow we should have a party we should we
can't use points to pay for the party
though in police
i'm in how about cabo let's go to cabo
i'm in we're heading there man i'm
telling you i love it great question
diane but a heart a hard answer yeah
well
because it's passive aggressive so you
need a wrong answer i mean yeah what's
wrong with doing this because we're not
going into any more debt yes you are
you're going into debt because you're
not paying off the debt that you have
because you're spending money that you
don't have to do crap you shouldn't do
there's a just there it is
it's a simple thing but
it's your life darling you get to do
what you want to do the problem is you
ask our opinion and we are an expert on
our opinion
we've led more people out of debt and
into wealth than any other brand in
america today
but you do what you want to do kiddo